hmm
[Music]
all right so Tiff and I love
incorporating each of our cultures into
our lifestyle and when it comes to
making food for the family I've started
fusing foods of my Chinese Heritage with
some motifs Mexican heritage and today
I'm taking the Chinese rice dish called
Zhong and combining it with one of his
personal favorites the tamale if you
don't know what a Zhong is it's a rice
dumpling made of glutinous rice it's
stuffed with different fillings and it's
wrapped in bamboo leaves and it honestly
looks just like a tamale and just like
the tamale Jones are made with the whole
family gathered around it's like a
family event festive everyone's helping
out and so since they're so similar to
each other I figured why not try
infusing the two together and making a
tamale that has the traditional fillings
of the Jung so let's get started we're
first gonna start by rehydrating some
dried shiitake mushrooms pour some hot
water over it and wait about 30 minutes
to an hour for it to plump up next we're
going to take two pounds of pork
shoulder AKA pork butt but really it's
just pork shoulder we're gonna keep it
up throw her into a walk and saute it
for about two minutes or until it starts
to Brown Next we're gonna make your
kitchen smell really good we're gonna
add some aromatics ginger five slices of
Ginger and two green onions but we're
only gonna use the white bulby part of
the green onion give it a nice little
smack smack because you want to expose
the fibers to get more of the flavor out
so work in the aromatics in the wok with
the pork it's gonna start smelling real
good and in comes the liquid ingredients
one cup of Chinese rice wine it's gonna
give the dish its floral Essence four
tablespoons of light soy sauce this is
our sodium and two tablespoons of dark
soy sauce this is also sodium but more
for the color so dark soy sauce gives
you that nice beautiful brown color
right light soy sauce doesn't actually
color the meat so as a Chinese cook it's
really important for you to have light
soy sauce and dark soy sauce in your
pantry one cup of chicken broth this is
just store-bought chicken broth if you
want to go super fancy you can also just
have nice flavorful homemade chicken
stock next are dry ingredients four PODS
of star anise four bay leaves and two
tablespoons of sugar if you got Rock
Sugar even better I don't because I just
never go out of my way to buy Rock Sugar
give it a stir working all the
ingredients and cook on low heat for two
hours essentially we're braising this
meat on for the dough for the tamales in
a large mixing bowl add 2 3 cup of lard
and we're gonna whisk it so that it gets
worked in and starts to fluff up a
little bit add two cups of Masa Arena
just a stickler for me pronouncing
Spanish properly one teaspoon of baking
powder half a teaspoon of salt and
honestly you could probably throw in
some of that braising liquid into this
probably give some color and some nice
little flavorings I totally didn't
because I totally didn't think about it
until after I made the whole thing
anyways you're gonna mix all the dry
ingredients together with the lard until
it starts looks like crumbles or sand
and I remember from the beginning of the
video we had the dried shiitake
mushrooms that were rehydrating take
some of that water and add it to your
dough to help moisten up the dough and
what we're looking for here is like a
peanut butter texture by the way the
shiitake mushroom water
very Umami very very Umami and next
we're going to pull our braised pork out
and shred it what we're trying to do is
get very fine shreds of pulled pork so
we can turn this into a filling for the
tamales now back over the braising
liquid we're gonna discard the ginger
the the green onions star anus anise and
bay leaves next what we're gonna do is
skim the fat out of our braising liquid
because we were braising a pork butt
there's a lot of fat and butts so take a
skimmer and skim all the fat out this is
the most time consuming and tedious
thing to ever do but it's well worth it
because we're going to use this braising
liquid and we're going to put it into
our pulled pork so once you have the fat
skimmed we're gonna add a cornstarch
slurry which is basically three
teaspoons of cornstarch and three
teaspoons of water and we're gonna
thicken up our sauce so raise the temp
cook it for a few minutes and add about
a cup of this into your pulled pork mix
it all together and voila we have our
tamales fill in Now set that aside and
we're gonna work on our mushrooms we're
gonna just slice it up super easy now it
is time to assemble our tamales we're
using rehydrated corn husks here that's
been boiled in water a lot of
rehydrating dried food items for this
one being a Chinese staple shiitake
mushrooms and now corn husk which is a
Mexican staple anyways take a tablespoon
of dough and put it onto your corn husk
and press the dough down so it lays flat
into a nice little sheet add about a
tablespoon of pork filling onto your
sheet of dough and you want to arrange
it into like a little line down the
center of the dough and then top the
fill in with some mushrooms and then the
trickiest part here is to fold it over
you want to fold it over gently down
towards the center and carefully wrap it
up into the corn husk take a small thin
strip of corn husk and we're gonna use
that to tie our tamale up so that it
doesn't fall apart while we steam it
repeat this step a million times as many
tamales as you can make hopefully not a
million because that's a lot of tamales
now Place each of your tamales into a
tamale
tamalera tamalera I can't do that one
and steam for one hour once done ticket
them all out unwrap it and the way I
like to serve this is spoon some of that
braising liquid right on top and top it
off with some of that green onions that
we set aside earlier and Bam we have a
Chinese tamale
[Music]
fire now Tiff thinks some of my
Creations are completely wacky by this
one
oh she loved this one mm-hmm
mm-hmm good job honey
that is really good actually the
mushroom makes it really interesting
that's what it was I thought it was a
tendon
they're really good with the muscle
yeah this is perfect for Christmas with
your family actually
not a big fan of the mushroom
the texture's throwing me off
um it doesn't belong but the pork is the
pork flavored so like the Chinese
Sazon
with the tamale which is really good you
can finish yours fast I know I'm wearing
a second one huh
the whole thing
we'll buy it
wifey approved if you like this video
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe and if you want more food
content let me know what kind of foods
you want to see me make till next time
thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you